boa tarde a todos como investigador aqui
nesta casa da unir será vai muitas
pessoas me perguntam porque é o
investimento que se faz na investigação
é também an por que porque os centros de
investigação a perguntas também porque
senão será um só servidores do dinheiro
para em busca de um pouco mais da cruz'
idade humana e é um pouco mais da busca
dar a conhecer a natureza vai para
responder esta questão e eu senti físico
nada mais natural do que ir buscar o
exemplo do céu um sítio que eu visito
frequentemente e prescreveu dizer que
para a descoberta do bóson de higgs o
famoso bóson de higgs chamada partícula
a partícula de deus foram investidos 10
mil milhões de anos e também com o
orçamento do servo orçamento anual são
milhões de euros e portugal contribui
com 1% e 3 sendo que as empresas
portuguesas que têm contratos com o
cérebro elas conseguem recuperar todo
esse investimento que é feito mas
perguntas a trace do boss não digas o
único resultado que vai todo este
investimento é que a contribuição é que
teve pracinha da mãe de facto é para
atingir estes feitos foi necessário anf
charlie mito o desenvolvimento de novas
tecnologias
isso enriquecemos com capacidades
tecnológicas únicas e como por exemplo
também conhecemos web foi inventado no
céu nem todos nós usamos é toda hora
também o desenvolvimento de computadores
e de eletrônica permitem osso nós
podermos usufruir de uma série de
dispositivos nas nossas casas de nós no
nosso cotidiano
mas o que teve mais impacto talvez tenha
tido mais impacto é algo muito sensível
pracinha da redação
eu posso não sei se sabe mas nos últimos
já há 30 anos
a nossa esperança de vida cresceu 30
para 80 é impressionante mas isso não
foi por acaso e só foi possível com o
avanço das tecnologias do diagnótico e
tecnologias tratamento médico
essa nós olhávamos próximo a eles agora
vamos começar a perceber onde é que vêm
essas tecnologias conseguem ver a
semelhança não posso garantir que a
maior parte de toda esta tecnologia teve
origem nas crenças física de partículas
e conforte benefício pra será como
podemos observar agora trago vos um
outro exemplo exemplo mais pessoal onde
nós também tentamos projetar próxima
nada investigação que realizamos aqui na
universidade do havaí
é um sentimento desenvolvemos um
dispositivo inovador que tem
características únicas para o controle
da dose de radiação no tratamento do
cancro por radioterapia esta dispositivo
está mais vocacionado para o cancro da
próstata e e outros que utilizam uma
técnica que chama braquiterapia em que
consiste na inserção das pequenas
sementes radioativas junto das zonas
afetadas junto com os tumultos matando
assim estas querem cancerígenas e
aumentando a propriedade de cura é o
nosso dispositivo
basicamente é constituído por uma fibra
ótica cintilante que quando sujeito à
radiação produz luz depois recuperada
uma fibra mais longa uma fibra ótica que
transporta essa luz até um sensor
ultrassensível que produz uma resposta
elétrica que é proporcional à dose
angulada nesse sensor e assim que nós
realizamos essa menina é além da alta
sensibilidade deste dispositivo é suas
pequenas dimensões que são únicas
nas suas características permitem a
inserção destes positiva
vejo-o de agulhas e o cateter dentro do
paciente e poder controlar a dose está
certo pose tava em tempo real e numa
região específica que exprime permite
fazer um planejamento com a distribuição
destas pequenas sementes focando a
região queremos tratar evitando ao mesmo
tempo regiões saudáveis órgãos e tecidos
saudáveis e isso vai trazer de uma maior
eficiência ano no tratamento desta este
tratamento também o que importa agora é
pensar no coração do paciente
quais são os benefícios próprios sinto
bem esse benefício acaba é na questão da
eficiência do tratamento diminui
drasticamente as complicações pós
tratamento preserva os tecidos saudáveis
que o que é importante os órgãos
saudáveis ea diminui também é um cidadão
futuras intervenções vai mais para
pensar nesse dispositivo como um produto
eu retirei a minha pergunta
investigadora existe um papel de
empreendedor e em conjunto com ongs
montinho e o flip castro
concorremos com um projecto denominado
mil reais em um concurso da exploração
de empresas o bc e é mike portugal ao
fim de algum tempo um dá alguma
interação e dar algum trabalho associava
acabamos vencedores na categoria de
dispositivos médicos e de saúde
ian a caixa capital nós temos um prêmio
de investimentos e me lê los para
avançar com este projecto
portanto para criar a empresa new eyes e
também lançarmos a aventura de colocar o
nosso sistema o nosso dispositivo como
uma mais valia para o tratamento do
cancro
eu penso que depois desta nossa conversa
é podemos todos concluíram que a
investigação ea sociedade atual
andam de mãos dadas muito obrigado